What's even better than
playing your favorite game
on your phone?
Playing it on a big
screen TV in your living
room with a couple of friends.
I'm Josh Gordon.
And today, I'll show you how to
get your existing mobile game
working on Android TV.
Android TV is your
opportunity to develop
for both the big screen and
for mobile at the same time
and in the same APK.
That's because
Android TV is just
Android on a new form factor.
So can you run
your existing game
on the TV right out of the box?
Not quite, but
you're nearly there.
First, you'll need to
make a couple of updates
so it's compatible.
Of course, TVs have a lot
of hardware differences
with mobile.
For example, my TV
doesn't have a touchscreen
or an accelerometer.
But by properly structuring your
manifest and application code,
you can make your game
compatible with both form
factors.
Start by specifying
the activity that's
launched when the user selects
your app on the TV home screen.
Do so by adding the
Leanback Launcher
category to an intent filter.
Having this category
also lets the Play Store
know that your app is
compatible with Android TV.
Next, notice that
the Android TV home
screen uses a separate
launcher row for games.
And you'll want to make
sure your game is shown here
when it's installed.
To do so, just add an
Android isGame attribute
to your application element.
Now, Android TV uses banners
instead of icons to represent
your app on the home screen.
If you don't have a banner,
you'll need to create one.
It's a fixed size
drawable at 320 x 180.
Your banner should
always include
text that identifies your game.
And you should create a banner
for each language you support.
Now, specify the banner
in your manifest.
Also, in your
manifest, you'll need
to make sure you don't require
any hardware features that
are unavailable on the TV.
For example, if your game
requires a touchscreen
in the manifest, your app
won't be listed as compatible
with TVs in the Play Store.
So start by declaring that a
touchscreen is not required.
Next, check through your
manifest for other hardware
features you use on mobile, like
a camera or an accelerometer.
Be sure to also mark
these as not required.
Now, keep in mind that
some permissions can also
imply hardware requirements.
For example, using
the camera permission
creates an implicit
dependency on camera hardware.
To handle this, you'll need to
explicitly mark that hardware
as not required.
Next, declare that your app
uses the Leanback feature.
And be sure to set
Required to false,
so your game can also
be installed on mobile.
Now, at runtime, you can
check what type of device
your game is running on and
adapt its behavior accordingly.
To do so, use the
UI mode manager
and test if the current
device is a TV or mobile.
Also, by using the
package manager,
you can test if
specific hardware
is available on the
device at runtime.
Now, here's a gotcha
to be aware of when
you're porting your game.
You probably already
have code that
checks to see if there's an
active internet connection.
On mobile, commonly,
you just have
to worry about Wi-Fi and
cellular, but on Android TV,
you might also have Ethernet.
The best way to check for an
active internet connection
without having to
specify the type
is to use the
connectivity manager.
Now, let's talk about
how to control your game.
Instead of a
touchscreen, on the TV,
players control your game using
a D-pad remote control or more
advanced gamepad.
Most TVs ship with
just the remote.
So if your game supports
a simple input scheme,
you can potentially reach
every Android TV user.
Always show visual
controller instructions
in your game for both
types of controllers,
if you support them.
Google provides generic graphics
you can use for this purpose.
And drawing your
own is fine too,
just keep them
free from branding.
Now, if your game
requires a gamepad,
you should let players
know in the Play Store.
To do so, add the gamepad
feature to manifest,
but be sure to always
set it to required false.
This is a gotcha.
It must be false, because
gamepads are accessories,
and they might not be connected
at the time of purchase.
Instead of requiring
this feature,
check whether a
gamepad is connected
when your game starts up.
And here's something
else to be aware of.
TV controllers
periodically save energy
by going into sleep mode.
When this happens, they
disconnect from the TV.
To prevent this event from
interrupting your game,
you can subscribe
to it by adding
these lines to
your manifest, then
you can handle it in your game.
Check out this code
sample to learn all
about handling input devices
and events on the TV,
as well as how to handle
multiple connected game pads.
There are also a couple display
considerations to keep in mind.
First, the TV is always
in landscape mode.
And second, you should
be aware of overscan.
Overscan refers to the
tendency of some TVs
to clip the outside
of the display.
It's a historical problem that
isn't specific to Android.
To handle it, just avoid placing
important screen elements,
like a player's
score, within about 5%
from the edge of the display.
You can find more details
about overscan at this link.
Now, one of the most
powerful parts of Android TVs
is that they open
up new opportunities
for local multiplayered gaming.
For example, you can
use your Android phone
as a second screen and as a game
controller for your TV game.
You can enable this
technology, using an API called
Nearby Connections.
And you can see it in action
by watching this video.
We have tons of great resources
to help you learn more, which
can be found at these links.
Thanks, very much, for
watching, and happy gaming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]